I'm gonna start with dr. Marvin Chris
dr. Prince is holds effective position
at Cornell that has research and
teaching and extension responsibilities
his primary extension he is the primary
Extension liaison for the New York State
berry producers and he's also the chair
of the department of horticulture and
that may get his talk
up here
before dr. pert starts I do want to let
you folks know that I have
enabled you to put the full screen on so
that you can do that if you like or you
can keep it as a shorter screen and I'm
sorry we seem to have lost the chat box
so let me see if I can get that back
so now we have the ability for you folks
to ask questions during the presentation
put the full screen on and his listen
okay well happy Halloween everybody and
we want to talk today about weed
management and berries and it's a topic
that lots and lots of questions about
we've done some work on budgeting and
strawberries and we find that managing
weeds is the greatest expense that
strawberry growers incur except for
actually harvesting the fruit and some
stumps when we've done analysis we found
it up to 70% of the labor costs that
growers spend involves weed management
and part of that is because we grow our
strawberries under matted rows and we
have fields like this that are pretty
much bare fallow we put our little
strawberry plants in there and then we
hope that they produce runners during a
year and fill in but when you look at
that field you find that there's lots of
bare ground and lots of opportunities
for weeds to come in during that time
that strawberries are trying to grow and
establish themselves most of the
problems we have are in that first year
where there's a lot of bare ground in a
strawberry fields and we don't have a
whole lot of a very good herbicides
although that's changing a little bit
now more recently we've gotten some of
the materials that dr. Bruner is going
to share with you in a few minutes but
we're gonna talk about matted rows first
so we have all this bare ground people
go and they cut the flowers off to
encourage the runners to fill in the
runners fill in between the rows but
again even during these first several
months there's a lot of bare ground out
there and a lot of opportunities for
weeds to establish themselves
particularly when we irrigate and water
the ground in between the strawberries
and will occasionally get lots of weeds
growing between the rows and even more
weeds growing between the rows and then
this is when we get calls from growers
and I'll say what can I do I've got
weeds in my strawberries well it's often
pretty late to do much about it by that
but that's often times when we get the
call so what we want to do today is sort
of think about some ways we might be
able to manage our weeds without waiting
till we get to a point like that now a
fumigation is something that used to be
a little bit more popular than it is now
part of the reason for that is that
fumigation methyl bromide in particular
is being phased out and it's becoming
very expensive so growers that used to
use it for a weed management practice of
finding well it's just a little bit too
expensive for me to do that plus the
plastic
is difficult to dispose of the black
plastic mulches are used in a lot of
annual production systems and there's a
photograph in Florida where they use
black plastic and that helps control the
weeds too but one of the problems with
that is is a disposal problem and I
don't know what it's like in your state
but just this month in New York they
passed a law that saying you can't burn
any more no open burning and a lot of
growers would dispose of their plastic
by open burning so we can't do that
anymore
so this material is left to accumulate
if you don't have a way to recycle it
and I did some calculations a couple
years ago for a presentation I was gonna
give and I realized that strawberry
growers alone use enough plastic each
year to circle the earth 13 times that's
a lot that's a lot of plastic so the
question that we're interested in is are
the ways of preventing weeds in
strawberries out using a lot of plastic
without using fumigation without using a
lot of labor there's really three
strategies pretty obvious one is deplete
the weed seed bank to prevent seed
dispersal to the field in other words
try not to get weeds into the field
before you start secondly prevent
germination and or establishment once
you have the berries in the ground and
then thirdly remove weeds that up here
and unfortunately most people wait till
that third step and then try to figure
out how to remove weeds that appear
without putting a lot of effort into the
first two
one of the experiments we did a few
years ago was looking at replant disease
in strawberries and we had an old
strawberry field we took it out of
strawberries and then we planted eight
different treatments into that old
strawberry field and then we planted
strawberries after these two year
rotations in between the strawberries so
for example we had mowed weedy fallow
fumigation and alfalfa mustard kale
sweet corn raw you can read the
treatments up there and we also had
continuous strawberry and then we took
these cover crops out and we planted
strawberries again and have a lot of
data here on how these plants responded
and root pathogens and everything like
that but I just wanted to show you the
data on the weenus of the treatments
after these cover crops and this would
be in the first year that strawberries
are growing so the first column you see
is sort of a methyl bromide fumigation
treatment this is about as good as it
gets when you fumigate and implant your
strawberries there are a few weeds and
some of the treatments had a lot of
weeds like when you go right in with
strawberries and follow strawberries
again or you know mow you don't do
anything except mow the weeds that
doesn't really help a lot but what I
wanted to point out was that some of
these treatments like kale sweet corn
rye rotation or a rotation of mustards
did a pretty good job at managing weeds
and suppressing weeds in that first year
and it was certainly a lot less
expensive and had a lot less environment
impact the methyl bromide fumigation so
that was a good thing one of the
questions we wanted to ask ourselves for
several questions but when you have
weeds in strawberries like how much weed
growth is acceptable how much can a
grower tolerate is the only good weed a
dead weed are there times when weed
growth can be tolerated and there are
times when weeds are very competitive
with strawberry plants so the way we try
to answer that question was we took up
first
your strawberry field and we divided up
into plots and we had weeds growing in
those plots for specific lengths of time
and for specific months of the year so
for example we had weeds growing just
during the month of June and then for
the rest of the season
we removed the weeds by hand just for
the month of July just for August just
for Sept
and then we had combinations of two
months and in combinations of three
months and then we had weeds all year
long and then we let the strawberries go
through the winter and in the following
season in the first year we harvested
the plants to see what impact the weeds
and the first year had on yields the
second year so here are some of the
plots in summer wienie in some art and
these are the data here the way you read
this is if there's an X that means
weaves were present in each of those
months and so here we have weeds present
June July August and September basically
all year long those plants the following
year those plots produce one runner and
292 grams of fruit and you can see how
this is set up three months two months
one month but what so the first thing I
want to do is look at the one month
periods so these are weeds in June we
just in July just in August and just in
September let's go over here and look at
runner production and we can see that
the later the weeds were present the
more runners we had in the same way with
yields yields were higher if the one
month of weed pressure was late in the
season relative to one month early in
the season we can do the same thing when
we look at a two month period of weed so
here are weeds in June and July and we
can look at our yield a little over a
thousand grams for plot but we had the
same two months of weed pressure but
later in the season our yields were two
and a half times as much and we can see
the same pattern with runners a lot more
runners when the weeds were late
compared to when we pressure was early
and we can do the same thing for three
months of weed pressure very little
yield but when the three months of weed
pressure was later about three or four
times as much yield and we've done this
experiment for a couple of different
years and it's pretty clear that in
first year plantings early season weed
pressure is much worse than late season
we pressure
so getting the weeds out of those first
year plantings early really can make a
difference
weeds later in the season not so much of
an impact
so how do you keep those weeds out well
we did it by hand but that's a lot of
work are there other ways that you can
use cultivation to remove weeds early in
the season when they're most problematic
well there are lots of different tools
out there to manage weeds and strawberry
growers tend to use a rototiller and
herbicides but there are some other
tools out there that look like they
might have some potential in
strawberries so we wanted to see how
those those work so this is a standard
way that growers cultivate their
strawberries they take a multivator
roto tiller go down the rows but the
problem with that device is that on the
downstroke it compacts the soil and
makes a compacted layer about six inches
down and on the upstroke it just brings
wheat seeds up to the surface and lets
them germinate what would be better is
if you could do some shallow cultivation
where you're only cultivate in the first
couple of inches rather than all the way
down and bringing wheat seeds to the
surface and some of these tools do that
these finger weeders shallowly cultivate
around the plants all these are onions
not strawberries but you can see the
principal
gets right up close to the plant these
flex tine harrows shallowly cultivate
they don't bring weed seize up to the
surface and you just drive this device
relatively quickly over the field these
tines vibrate back and forth and knock
the small weeds up
by the ground this is something called a
Reggie wieder and the way this works is
you sit in the back here and you pull
along you straddle the row and the
operator pulls these wheels in and out
and they spin and they move spin the
weeds out from around the plants so you
can just move it in and out as you go
down the row and this device here spins
and you can see it only cultivates real
shallowly and it doesn't bring weed
seeds up to the surface we've had real
good luck with that in strawberries and
also this device here which is called a
brush hoe and the way this thing works
is like a giant street sweeper it mounts
on the back of a tractor and these will
spin and they spin the weeds out as you
go over the row and straddle the row
also it kicks up a little bit of dust
that settles back down onto the top of
the row and it almost acts like a mulch
layer of dust here you see it's sweeping
through some cabbage and it kicks up
some dust it sweeps out their weeds and
it makes this layer of dust back on the
ground and here is the brush show after
it's gone over our young planting of
strawberries you can see it's done a
pretty good job of sweeping out the
weeds and it leaves this layer of dust
on the top which seems to prevent
subsequent weeds from germinating so I'm
going to show you some sequence of
photos here that look at some of the
different ways that weeds have been
managed in first year strawberries using
these different tools so here's a weed
management tool this is Devin all after
planting so you can see the strawberry
rows here and Devin all was applied and
then that was it walked away from it a
couple of several weeks later you come
back and you're getting some weeds going
into strawberries that's if you do
nothing at all this is sort of the
standard way that growers will do it
they might use some Devin all but then
they would come in with a multivator and
go through and wrote a tail between the
rows and of course that knocks down the
weeds and you're left with a situation
like this so it's pretty clean but it
did use that multivator and generally
this area here will regrow weeds very
quickly after
multivator as soon as it rains again
you'll get weeds coming up in this area
here this is a flex time hair this is
the one that I showed you that vibrates
when you drive over the rows it vibrates
to the small weeds out of the ground and
it does a pretty good job in the first
several weeks after strawberries are
planted you can see it keeps the
planning really clean here we didn't do
anything here no hand weeding we just
drove over it with the flextime Harrow
every few weeks now you can't let the
weeds get too tall or this won't work
the weeds have to stay small almost
anakata leading stage but it's a good
way to cultivate shallowly the
difficulty we found with this flex tine
Harrow that once the runners start to
form in a strawberry you can't use it
anymore because the runners get caught
up in the tines and we get lots of weeds
at the end of the season if we've used
this flex tine Harrow
it doesn't it just stimulates a lot of
weed germination we get lots of weeds at
the end and will contrast that with a
brush show where this is early in the
season and again very few weeds between
the rows and late in the season the same
thing
very few weeds between the rows even
though these were not hand pulled
afterwards this is just a tool the flux
pine harrows stimulates we growth
particular after you're done using it
the brush hoe seems to keep the weeds
suppress a little bit longer probably
cause of that layer of dust that's
formed on top of that here's some data
on the weed biomass from these different
treatments the multivator you know
really knocks down the weeds you don't
get many weeds the flex tine Harrow gave
us lots of weeds and you saw a photo of
that before that even when we use the
flux fine Harrow then add herbicide we
still get quite a few weeds the finger
reader did a pretty good job of reducing
weeds the same as a brush hoe so these
were very effective the herbicide alone
you know it doesn't give us a whole lot
of weed suppression and but if you use
an herbicide on a multivator this is
more or less the standard practice of
growers use it does keep the weeds down
a lot but the question is you know how
much does it cost to do that
how many times you have to go over the
field and what are your yields and so
impacted by that so here are the yields
from the multivator and you know
reasonable yields here but the yields
are even better with a finger wieder and
summer besides even if flex tine Harrow
if we use it early on to keep the weeds
out and then use an herbicide you know
the yields are pretty high remember
these plots were kind of weedy but they
were weedy at the end of the season not
at the beginning of the season as long
as we keep the weeds out at the
beginning of season you know the yields
gonna be pretty high even if they're
weedy or later on if we go down here to
the herbicide you know the herbicide
alone doesn't give you enough weed
suppression you definitely get an impact
on yield so we can't just rely on
herbicides to manage our weeds and
strawberries we've got to use some
cultivation too and here's a standard
practice herbicide plus the multivator
so although the brush hoe and a finger
wieder were more expensive to used in a
single herbicide application about
$1,000 each in terms of all your labor
and costs everything going into that
there are much more effective at
controlling weeds and $1,000 worth of
strawberries isn't that much so you can
easily make up for that by using one of
these tools the brush hoe was also more
effective and cheaper to run three
hundred dollars for the year than
standard cultivation because it required
far few passes only three passes through
the field and two hand weeding and no
herbicides and we were able to keep the
field really really clean whereas with
standard rototilling we had to go
through more times and we had to do more
hand weeding the disadvantage of a brush
hoe is as a initial expense
so let's look at another strategy and
that's planting strawberries through
skilled sods so rather than have a bear
field where you plant your strawberries
and then you wait a whole year for those
runners to establish and you have all
that bearish soil the idea here is
almost like no-till planting established
a cover crop kill the cover crop plant
the strawberries into that cover crop
and then see how well your wheeze is
depressed and how well the strawberry
plants grow so here's a field you can
see different cover crops growing here
here's hairy vetch this looks like rye
there's a bunch of different types of
cover crops out here and so what we did
was we grew these in the fall through
the winter the following spring we
sprayed them out and then we planted
strawberries in a narrow sort of ribbon
row into these various mulches so you
can see them going across here and we
looked at what happened after that so
here's a planning of us which was killed
sod we added a little bit of straw to
the surface and we added some herbicide
and pre-emergent herbicide and it keeps
the weeds down really really well for
that first year and you don't have to go
in and cultivate you don't have to go in
and add additional herbicide here's a
plot that had no herbicide it was just
killed rye and his strawberries are
planted into that killed rye and it's
very clean here's another plot very
clean relative to some of these other
plots which are more treated normally
with some cultivation and this is nut
sedge here a lot of this is nut sedge
and it's a pretty bad weed but you can
see with this treatment here it's does a
pretty good job of suppressing it
so again a close-up of ribbon row and
killed rye residue and strong malt put
on top of that for the first year and
this is a second year planning and you
can see the with no hand weeding no
cultivation or anything no herbicides
the second year the plants look pretty
darn good considering that we didn't do
a whole lot of we didn't have a whole
lot of we didn't put it into that so I
think that this is something that we can
think about and growers should consider
particularly is the cost of some of
these materials go up the challenge has
been planting these strawberries into
the killed sod we had to do this by hand
we took the tines off a rototiller and
left one little wrote one tied on there
so we could do a little strip but more
recently they have some tools now that
actually can cut a groove into the sod
and then plant no-till into these killed
sides and it works a lot better than
some of the tools we used to have these
are pretty new pretty expensive but the
point is the technology is coming along
that we ought to be able to do this in a
few years without a whole lot of effort
the last strategy I wanted to mention
was interplanted cover crops and this
would be something you do after the
strawberries are growing for a couple of
years again after harvest you renovate
the strawberries you mow off the leaves
you cultivate in between the rows and
then again you have this bare ground
situation for the rest of the season and
you try to keep the weeds out of and
right after renovation you mow the
leaves off you cultivate then the
recommendation is to come in and put on
sin bar or never at all or some material
to keep the weeds from growing in
between the rows we ask ourselves
question why can't we plant something
between rows that we'd rather have than
a bunch of weeds and if we plant that
crop and it's something that crowds out
the weeds but then dies itself it might
not be so much of a problem to have
something in there that dies off and
doesn't allow it weeds to grow so here's
a field where we have we strawberry
plants in an established bed and between
the rows of strawberries we planted
Sudan grass you plant in sudan grass
after renovation late July early August
it grows up and then in late September
early October it dies because a frost
come so then the following season or
actually later on that year you have
these strawberry rows you have a bunch
of dead residue in between them from the
Sudan grass but you don't have any weeds
because this is an grass displaced them
in the following spring this residue
disappears over the winter or you mulch
the plants anyway it was straw and the
following year you have planted it looks
just like this you can see there Sudan
grass residue still here but it's
relatively clean from weeds so these are
some strategies that we've used to think
about managing weeds and strawberries
without relying so much on herbicides so
just to review cover crops or crop
rotations to reduce weed pressure before
planting we find a grain crops such as
sweet corn are really good in a rotation
because a couple of reasons
one is they have a very different growth
habit in strawberries so the weeds that
grow between corn tend to be different
than those that
might establish themselves in a
perennial broadleaf plant plus you can
use herbicides on corn that aren't
labeled for strawberries so you can
clean things up pretty well with the
corn before you move into the
strawberries so you do a good cover crop
rotation you're ready to plant the
strawberries we find that you know one
or two applications are roundup before
you plant the strawberries works well to
kill the perennial weeds because once
you have strawberries establish is very
difficult to remove weeds from them
particularly perennial weeds because
strawberries are broadleaf perennial
plant and most of the weeds we have are
broadleaf perennials and there's not a
lot of selective products that can
remove the bad broadleaf weeds and leave
the broadleaf plant as you want alone
early you know focus attention early in
the season if you have limited labor
I'm at a time the best use of that is to
remove those weeds for the first two or
three months if the strawberries have
been planted and not later we've also
looked at this in subsequent years what
about managing weeds and established
plantings we found the same thing that
once the plants are established you can
weeds have very little impact on
subsequent you know it might look bad
and it looks like all there's lots of
weeds in there but the impact they have
on strawberries after they're
established if you can keep the weeds
out that first year get the strawberries
in the ground and get them well
established you can have weeds come in
and it won't impact your yield unless
you have tremendous weed pressure so
they're really good once they're
established and then some alternatives
you know playing through those killed
sods I showed you using some of these
newer cultivation tools that cultivate
shallowly don't compact the soil and
don't bring weed seeds to the surface
they're good and then there's a bunch of
herbicides that work as well and we're
going to be talking about those in just
one minute also keep the area's mowed
around the plantings don't blow loud we
cease to blow into the planning from
fields close by that are producing weed
seeds and then this whole concept of
using interplant of cover crops
particularly with things like Sudan
grass or oats things that winter kill I
think has a lot of promise
so the question is are you able to use
less straw for winter mulch if you have
Sudan grass and your planted into
berries theoretically I think that would
be the case what we found is that the
Sudan grass actually it doesn't hold up
real well to the winter and part of that
reason for that is we don't let it get
tall so it doesn't get real woody and
lignified so when you only let it when
you plant it in early August and it only
grows 2 or 3 feet high it's not real
woody so it does break down pretty quick
what we found is it really helps hold
the straw on the rows even though it
might not allow you to get by with less
straw
it does help hold on to rows and keeps
it from blowing off when you do mulch in
early December so with that Laura why
don't we put up Robins
and if anybody else has any question for
Marvin here while I change things around
a bit that would be this is the time to
Hira quiet group today must be Friday
okay
we got some people typing
same problem I had before I
all right let's get this back where it
needs to be
all right we've got a few people typing
so why don't we just give them just a
second and see if there's some questions
for Marvin before I introduce Robin
don't know if they're typing a question
or if they're talking to each other it's
hard to tell
all right here we go we have a couple of
questions Marvin Jeff Hall asks if
renovation would be the same with sag
ground as bare ground
yeah with the sod ground we actually
don't have sod between the rows of
strawberries that grass is the Sudan
grass is an annual grass and it's only
planted after July and it's only growing
for a couple of months so it doesn't
really establish the sod like you might
think of it it actually dies off and
that's why we want it so by the time
fall comes we have you know some residue
on the ground but the Sudan grass is not
living so it's not the same as saw
ground and for small farmers are the
crops that would grow well interspersed
with in berry rows
I don't think so for strawberries
strawberries are low to the ground and
anytime you plant something that
produces shade strawberries don't like
it and you have the rose plant is so
close together anyway for feet but I
don't think it would really make sense
to plant something between strawberry
rose now if you're talking about
blueberries and the blueberries are
small you might be able to think about
that but not for strawberries the corn
by product we use a maze
corn gluten meal as a pre-emergent
herbicide we tested that we found out
that in strawberries it works quite well
in a dry year but when it rains a lot
and so wet year that corn gluten meal
also has a lot of nitrogen in it and
actually I made our weed problem worse
so if you can predict the weather you
can determine if it's good to use or not
but at least in our situation any time
we had a wet year we got more weeds from
the fertilizer into the nitrogen in that
product than we did when we had a dry
year well I'd say down here we do have a
link to Robin's website that gives
sources of those pieces of cultivation
equipment and that's on the final
portion of this webinar so there is a
link that dr. Belinda has there that you
can get some more information about that
our experience with different soil types
is somewhat limited you know I think
stones are more of a problem than soil
type in our experience and I will say
too that when we were looking at
planting in sort of killed sod sandy
soils work a lot better than heavier
clay soils Robin do you have any
comments on them yeah hold on a sec I
can comment on the different types of
soils can you hear me initially when we
got the brush hose they came from Europe
and we were told that the guards were
supposed to actually be run one inch in
the soil and you can't do that with
stony soils which we have here at the
research farm so we purposely raised the
guards so that they were above the rows
by about an inch to an inch and a half
which is one of the reasons we get the
dry movement of the dry soil that
creates that layer that doesn't let the
weeds emerge through it so we have not
had any difficulties using this machine
on either Stoney or eel silt type soils
the problem we have run into is that
when they're very wet then the brushes
pick up too much of the soil and it's
very difficult to clean them we have
another comment that sometimes Prouty
about circumcision
helps with nematodes and better soil
health and thank you very much Thomas
and there was a question from Brent
about of the killed covers are there
differences in fruit wrap problems the
following spring
okay we though the kill covers are there
differences in fruit rot problems of
following spring not in terms of the
fruit rot itself but in a root rots yeah
there's a lot of differences in pre
plant cover crop how that affects root
pathogens but I'm not aware of we
haven't found anything and I'm not aware
of data that show an effect of a pre
plant cover crop on fruit rots the
following spring all right great
we're going to move now into dr.
falender's presentation dr. Robin bill
endure holds a faculty position with
with Cornell University in the
Department of horticulture and she
focuses her research and extension
programming on weed control in vegetable
and fruit and we're very happy to have
her she's recently back from a trip to
India and dr. falender thank you very
much
good afternoon I'm pleased to have an
opportunity to visit with you I have to
say right up front that I only picked up
fruit in night in 2006 and I have been
focusing largely on developing data to
support new registrations of herbicides
particularly for the planting year of
strawberries and so what I will be
showing you today is some of the work
that we've been doing and are trying to
move into the registration process
what you see on the screen is a list of
the ones the herbicides which are pretty
much currently registered for
strawberries prowl h2o was just recently
registered in 2007 and so some of you
may not have had much opportunity to
look at that it's currently registered
for a pre plant
pre transplant at least one day before
transplanting and then subsequently can
be used between rows as long as you
leave 35 days before harvest the goal to
Excel is registered for use in
strawberries but it's a rather strange
registration because it only allows use
pre transplant 30 days and only in the
very first year it cannot be used
subsequently which makes it somewhat I
think hard to imagine using we are going
to as you'll see later working with the
new product goaltender which is not yet
registered in strawberries and that has
some other problems associated with
registration but we will talk a little
bit about that later Chateau is now
registered for pre transplant
applications as long as it's going to be
done on plastic it can also be used
spring and fall when the plants are
dormant obviously many of you have used
Deb devran all some of you have used
axel and some are you unsure using sim
bar it's been around a long time post
emergence to 4d has been around forever
aim is now registered as a pre
transplant burned down or two row
middles using protective shields stinger
is now registered on strawberries which
I think presents quite a good
combination of weeds that can be
controlled with that and then select
also now known as select max and post
can also be used for specifically
controlling post emergence emerged grass
weeds
we are currently looking at this group
of herbicides for applications in new
plantings dual Magnum mining you I'm
sure have used in other crops reflux has
been relatively recently registered in a
number of crops
it's a pre emergence but it also has
residues residual activity as well as
some post emergence activity Spartan is
a new one which is currently registered
in cabbage not in New York State and
I'll talk a little bit more about that
later goaltender which is flowable
formulation as opposed to a EC
formulation of the goal and tends to be
somewhat less injurious when it's
applied post emergence it also has
somewhat less weed control because of
the same thing but it is being moved
forward slowly cap roll is an old
product it's actually labeled on carrots
in Canada and we're trying we're awfully
close to getting it registered on
carrots in the US as well it is at
rising and so it has some of the similar
type characteristics in terms of weed
control as atrazine and as prints app
chateau which i have here as a new
evaluation as already labeled for
certain uses we're trying to change the
use pattern somewhat on that and prints
app is being considered for registration
because it's been registered for many
years in Washington and Oregon and now
that it's going through a rear edge
astray ssin process the company is
indicated that we can move forward with
trying to get it used in other parts of
the country this will just give you a
couple of birds eye views of some of
these things this is a trial that we
actually planted in 2008 and the data
I'm going to show you from that are from
that trial you can tell what our weed
pressures are like you can hardly see
the strawberries and prahl h2o does a
pretty nice job at least initially it
doesn't last the full season but it does
a very good job initially in
does not hurt the strawberry plants
these are applied the day before
transplanting here is the dual Magnum
and we've got three separate rates there
and I have to say these were applied the
day after transplanting and you can see
we have pretty good weed control we did
see a little bit of injury at the
highest rate but it did not last long
unfortunately in a year like 2009 when
we repeated this but we put it on pre
transplant and had huge rain events very
shortly after planting we did see some
significant stunting with the dual and
so one has to be a little cautious as we
go forward with creating the right
information for the companies to put the
information on the labels that there are
certain times in certain occasions when
there's likely to be more injury than
others
this is principal however have a
correction to make on this one I didn't
it's this before we sent it to Laura so
she couldn't change it the one on the
far right where it says print set three
times at point one pounds active
ingredient per acre is in fact not
Prince F it is sin bar the one on the
left is the application rate which is
currently used in Washington and Oregon
and it's usually put on either 30 days
pre-transplant or some people are
putting it on in the fall again two
dormant in that case we did see a little
bit of early injury with this but really
not significant a colleague of mine Brad
may Jack in New Jersey who many of you
I'm sure know has suggested that a
better way to do this is to apply
princess at three separate times roughly
two weeks apart post-transplant and as
you can see in this picture there is
somewhat less stunting in this we had
almost no stunting with this particular
application the sin bar applied at three
separate occasions which I understand
from Marvin is done routinely in Canada
in our particular case did not cause it
much in the way of injury but we also
had grass control problems and it may be
that the rate that that's used at is a
little bit marginal with regard to
controlling grasses
this is Chateau on the left on the right
you have the traditional application of
three ounces applied 30 days
pre-transplant and in 2008 we had quite
a bit of rain and I would have to say
that that three ounce rate even 30 days
prior to transplanting cause as you can
see there a significant injury applied
one day pre transplant at one third of
the rate you can see that we have very
little in the way of crop injury and we
have excellent weed control with both of
them
here are on the left is reflux reflux
has a lot of potential for both pre and
particularly in strawberries
pre-emergence activity on a lot of
troublesome broadleaf weeds however it
can only be applied prior to
transplanting and subsequent years it
would have to be applied to dormant
plants because it's post emergence
activity causes too much injury for the
crop the goaltender which is the
slightly safer version of goal to XL did
a pretty nice job and we do see some
injury in this but overall it's not too
bad
we also tried some rather strange
off-the-wall new things kicks or is a
product that is being marketed by BASF
and at this point they're not
particularly interested in strawberries
but what we did find is that applied
pre-transplant
in strawberries it actually does no harm
at all to the berries it unfortunately
has actually no activity on grasses and
that's what you see there is grasses
bandar in the middle is a product used
in Europe on other crops and even though
kicks or and bandura are the same mode
of action in terms of killing weeds you
can see that they have very different
behaviors in terms of their sensitivity
or their phyto toxicity because bandura
actually totally killed the strawberries
and then lastly occasionally throw in
things that I use in other crops just
for fun and so you have law rocks on the
far right and in 2008 you can see
there's no injury and really nice weed
control this was applied immediately
pre-transplant day before in 2009
however because as I mentioned earlier
with the dual Magnum because we got a
lot of rain shortly after the
transplanting we did see more injury
this year with the Lorax than we did in
2008
now this is one of two data tables
is it okay but I basically want to show
you what this one is hand weeding time
over here this is the hand weeding time
this whole column and what you should
see here is that for example although we
had very little in the way of injury
here with the jewel with the prowl we
did have relatively poor over the long
haul weed control and as a result your
hand weeding time is quite high soon bar
on the other hand as I mentioned we had
virtually no injury at all with those
three applications we didn't also have
very good weed control and so although
we have somewhat better weed control
them with Pro by itself shouldn't do it
that way you should do it out here okay
we do still have an appreciable amount
of time in terms of hand weeding the
princess which had initial injury we
begin to see better weed control and now
the weeding time comes down and chateau
which has the absolute shortest weeding
time very very little time it took
because it was so good even the three
days application or the through though
here it is the three times application
I'm sorry the one day before application
here we still have excellent weed
control and very very little keeping in
mind this is the first year so this is a
non fruiting year so we're getting
extremely good weed control and the hand
weeding time as I said has come way down
you have its with the dual Magnum you
had again initial injury relatively
slight overall pretty good weed control
with all of these and the weed control
hand weeding time is intermediate let's
call it that way but still not too bad
reflux again we have very little in the
way of injury good weed control except
for crabgrass because doesn't control
the grasses but the hand weeding time is
not bad and then of course kicks or
which had very little in the way of
injury had relatively poor weed control
and so our hand weeding time was back up
that one we moved to our next data slide
which is this last one this is yield
data that was collected in 2007 from a
transit planting trial in 2006 and I
have to say that it was our first time
hand harvesting strawberries and it took
forever
I had Meir Marvin for all of the work
he's doing in strawberries
you couldn't oh it was amazing the crew
was real real concerned about the amount
of time we spent hand weeding or hand
picking the strawberries so the yields I
felt were relatively variable both in
terms of numbers of runners per plant as
well as the yields they're highly
variable the significance level is not
particularly strong there are some
trends in the sense that here Chateau
and goaltender you did see particularly
with Chateau a slight reduction in the
number of runners and also a reduction
in the pounds and this was with the case
of jewel we also saw here significant
injury with this and we also saw a
reduction in the number of of the yields
per 20 meters with early glow again
overall the trends are not as noticeable
this one with these goaltender you do
see a slight reduction in terms of total
yields
then looking at the idea of where some
of these might fit into your current
practices prowl h2o at the top is
particularly good in controlling annual
grasses it does also pick up mustards
purslane and pigweed species if you have
I don't see this very often in
strawberry fields but velvetleaf is
suppressed by it as is lambsquarters
Spartan which I haven't mentioned much
up until now is largely a broadleaf weed
herbicide it's used pre plants plant and
it can also be used in dormant crops for
those of you from other parts of the
country that are not in New York State
you may see this registered already or
it will be registered soon the New York
Department of Environmental Conservation
or the Dec has had some problems with
FMC because they're not happy with water
tests and as a result FMC has not gone
forward with registering it yet in New
York State so that remains a little bit
up in the air chateau we would like to
see it its rate reduced so that we could
use it the day before transplanting as
opposed to waiting for the 30 days I
also would like to go back and revisit
with the company why they've got the
plastic on there because I think we can
do it with things without plastic reflux
as I mentioned we'll be good pre
transplant and subsequently in other in
later years could be used as a dormant
application is extremely good in
controlling several very difficult
broadleaf weeds particularly ragweed
mustards pigweeds and then dual Magnum
we've been trying to get that registered
off and on for some time particularly
because it controls nutsedge annual
grasses gallon saga it also does a good
job on pigweeds suppresses nightshades
and purslane
current registration status we have done
the residues for getting prints up
registered and those we'll be doing
going through analysis this coming here
so we expect registration on that in
2012 dual Magnum the 2008 trials are
complete the residence the residue
trials have been done and we expect
registration for that in 2011
with that I'd like to compute if there
are questions you know my hey there are
a couple of names
Robin Kristin callow asks of what what
is the active ingredient in reflux
okay the active ingredient in reflux is
full mess ofin in Canada is called
flexstar it is a PPO inhibitor it's
related to Blaser okay and roll bro so
hopefully that answers your question
there's a question about the hand
weeding times whether or not that is on
a per acre basis but I think it's
actually had a smaller basis
it's on it's on a plot basis that's 120
square 50 is wondering if dual Magnum
will have activity on henbit
I have very little experience with
henbit my guess is that it will not have
much activity on it okay great but now
does anybody else have any questions for
either Marvin or Robin
there's somebody typing here and I'll
wait for Brent to finish typing
nobody else has any questions we'll move
into the next phase the final phase of
the program
don't be nervous brah
Brett is actually asking me how does
soil organic matter affect activity of
some of these herbicides I know it's a
factor with sin bar and
Robin can you address that the the
higher the amount of organic matter the
more particulates there are in the soil
that the herbicides can bind to and so
that's why frequently you will see on
labels restrictions that if you have
muck soils you can't use certain
products and the reason is because you
either have to increase the rate
significantly or in order to get above
the level that's being bound up in the
soil so yes the higher the organic
matter the more the herbicides
particularly this pertains to soil
applied residual herbicides great so the
more you have the higher the more that
will be bound up yes okay okay and then
question about go ahead there's a
question about Queen Anne's lace yes
does anybody have any I don't know I'm
not sure what would do a good job on
that either
Marvin's shaking his head - neither one
of us has much hand background with that
a it's a a it's a perennial right also
is asking he says I'm thinking of very
low soil organic matter situations where
sin bar injures strawberries so if in
fact there is a really low organic
matter would you address could you
adjust the rate of sin bar appropriately
for that
technically yes if you're talking very
sandy soils most labels divide up their
rates on the bases and soils and they
will have a sandy soil a medium soil and
a muck soil or a high organic matter
soil and those rates are usually
adjusted to that yes you could do that
and then if you can see those other
questions there's a question about post
emergence control of chickweed
my answer on that is potentially stinger
yeah I think I did talk to a grower this
year that had very good luck with sting
around chickweed I was going to suggest
that's probably one of the better ones
at this point and then there's a soil pH
affecting herbicide activity
I
do you Marvin do you have any ideas on
that I mean the pH of the mix water
would but
marvin is suggesting that the pH might
have an impact on microbial breakdown
activities and that's why it might
indirectly have an effect on the
herbicides okay we've got another
question we really got them going here I
am contemplating cleaning strawberries
on Lampson sand mixed with Toms muck
grounds that I have grown sweet corn on
for several years wood prints up and
addressing herbicide residues effect
this so this is Marvin so on if you're
growing corn and you've used atrazine
and prints that before a real good way
to see whether it be a problem would be
due to a bioassay and you can use a
couple of things and but for
strawberries you know bean seeds are a
pretty good indicator if it if the
cucumber seeds either one of those so
you get your soil and you plant your
cucumber or your bean seeds in that soil
and then you get some soil that you know
you haven't treated that's kind of like
the same soil type and plant the same
being a cucumber seeds in that and then
bring it into your kitchen and put it in
the windowsill and let it grow and if
you see differences between the two that
might indicate that there's some residue
in the soil that might affect your
strawberries but if both grow the same
and everything looks normal
you don't see yellowing and so forth
then it's probably safe to plant but
yeah atrazine can carry over as can
prints out so you have to be a little
bit careful about that
all right great mario has a quest
question about using prowl on dual
Magnum for the first year the current
registration effort for dual Magnum is
not focused on the year of planting
however I don't see us having a problem
with trying to get that changed for the
registration when we actually get to it
both prowl and dual Magnum have good
potential in the first year in terms of
safety on the strawberries I think you
would select them more on the basis of
which weeds you knew had in the field
because they do behave somewhat
differently great and then Thomas
Crowley has a comment that soil pH will
affect triazine herbicides and Thank You
Thomas and then Kristen callow asks if
these presentations will be available on
the cornell website and yes they will be
and the link to that was on the first
page and I think I've included that link
as well on all of the login information
and if not I will try to do that for
further webinars
let's move into the final phase of this
which does allow you to look at some of
the other other information as far as
things that you can download there's a
information about cultivation tools a
handout that you can download onto your
own computer and then there's a
publication from a draw on organic
strawberry production which might be
of interest to some folks also there are
web URLs for some of these other
resources for instances the net mate
Endres excuse me production of
vegetables strawberries and cut flowers
using plastic culture there's a
cultivation tools source website that I
mentioned before and that URL is there
and then there's some concrete
comprehensive information about berry
production that's the berry website that
I also had mentioned and that is your
site that you would go to to get the
archived webinars
I do what to remind everybody that next
Wednesday this coming Wednesday November
4th is our first
we have management a webinar on
for blueberries and cranberries and we
have speakers Hilary Sandler of the
University of Massachusetts which is
going to she's going to be talking about
weed control on cranberries and dr. Eric
Hanson of Michigan State University is
going to be speaking more on blueberries
but we look forward to having those of
you who grow those crops to join us
before I introduce the last pot I want
to thank dr. Marvin Fritz and dr. Robin
Bell endure for speaking to us today
it's a great topic and covered a lot of
territory so I want to thank you I'm
going to open this last pod but if
anybody has any other questions before
we sign off I'd like you to do that just
go ahead and type them in the chat box
and I have one more pull through
you could just if people could just
weigh in on this there were saw a few
people that have signed off but if most
of you could just vote quickly and give
us some feedback about what was helpful
to you that would be wonderful
and this is your chance so please don't
hesitate to give us type in a question
if you've got it right in that chat box
we'd love to hear from you
we've had about ten more people that
might want to vote
while we're having people finish up we
have a question from Lynette who's
looking for control for horse metal
Marvin Robin if you'd like to chat can
you hear us
okay so we're not really sure about we
were talking about the horse nettle
issue we're not really sure of a label
product that works well on horses no I
think for a lot of those like the wild
carrot and horsing that all you really
got to clean them up before you plant
strawberries because once you plant it's
really you're really limited in what you
can do after that and an intern someone
commented they can grow strawberries in
between blueberry beds for the first
four or five years sure and we mentioned
that earlier that on crops with more
spacing between them particularly things
like blueberries you can enter crop the
only thing I would say you have to be
careful with there as pH strawberries
prefer a higher pH and blueberries so
you might have to pay close attention to
making sure that the pH isn't too low
for those strawberries and in the
horsetail equi sedum none of us know
what you can do about that even roundup
doesn't take that out before planting so
I think if you have horse tell you might
just not want to plant that field to a
low growing crop like strawberries and
look someplace else because you know
save that field for corn or something
that's grows taller you're just not
going to get the horse tail out with I
don't know of anything that works well
on that
that would even that wasn't hardly
strawberry plants
all right I've got Richard fires typing
in quick question couple more things if
you haven't voted on our final poll
please please give us some feedback and
if you also if you would like to send me
a note or give me a call email me
something if you have specific comments
that you'd rather not type into the chat
bar we're a third of the way through
these webinar series and I would be
really thrilled to hear from attendees
if they have some suggestions for ways
we can approve even other topics that in
the future you'd like to see covered and
a webinar type of format or things that
you absolutely hate about it we need to
hear them all so don't hesitate the last
question someone asked about a home
gardener suggestions I think a lot of
the things we talked about early on in a
presentation we're appropriate for
organic growers if you were referring to
herbicides for organic growers vinegar
is going to be labeled pretty soon as
that's gonna be labeled on a lot of
different crops that has burned down
action
it's an organic product and I imagine
strawberries to be on that label where
you can use it between the rows
particularly to burn down annual weeds
it start to come up it's a safe organic
product for you son strawberries a lot
of other crops
all right I'm gonna close our poll
I think Chautauqua County is still
typing I
what can you tell us about different
formulations for 240 is there such a
thing as I'm n + 2 4 D it comes of
different formulations that you're
referring to - 4 D I mean am I and E and
that's a salt product of 2 for D and
it's not nearly as volatile as some of
the other 240 products in other words it
doesn't vaporize and move as much so
that's the won't type that's recommended
for strawberries but having said that it
can still volatilize and move so you
wouldn't want to put it on strawberries
if you were near grapes because even
when using 2 4 d I mean salt you can
smell it shortly after that and growers
have had problems that had grapes nearby
so you want to be careful about that
in fact out in the Midwest they've had a
real hard time getting their grape
industry started because they use so
much - 4 D on wheat fields and even some
corn fields it's a cheap herbicide and
it's really caused problems with the
wine industry out there so yeah be
careful with it but if you do use it on
strawberries it's one of the few
broadleaf herbicides that don't affect
strawberries which are a broadleaf plant
but be careful if you have grapes or
asparagus
growing around your strawberry field
okay
all right to get that's it for questions
Thank You Marvin or Robin very much I
just want to let folks know that once
you're on the registration list for the
webinars you will continue to get
connection information and so for you
folks who are just strawberry growers
you could just delete my my emails when
they come up here and not interested but
if you are interested in maybe finding
out a little bit about these other berry
preps we'd love for you to log on so
thanks again for everybody attending and
that is the end of this webinar
you